yeah like any Grudge that I hold against
my parents it's gone because now I
accept that they were doing everything
they could yeah everything I went
through that was tough I was like this
is hard because of you you never helped
down he's like what about me he said
what about me I came to this country I
didn't know the language and nobody's
helping me out well I guess you're right
because I am a [__] spoiled brat and
as a parent now I'm just kind of like I
don't know how they did it with three
and he didn't speak the language and he
was an immigrant but also what's cool
about the second generation we can help
with homework and stuff and field trips
and like little things like that might
not seem like a lot but it was growing
up I I didn't think I was worthy for a
field trip I thought that was just for
the white people I'm like oh that's for
them my parents were like oh no my
sister's like oh I got an honor roll we
gotta go do an assembly they want the
parents no no no no no
[Laughter]
just in case